this week finally sees the release of
the Last Guardian again it's been a
development health the past 10 years the
sheer fact that it's finally here and
along with Final Fantasy 15 to boot is
this a real joy and got us thinking
about all the poor film still stuck in
development limbo from mega sequels
avatar 2 and Sherlock Holmes 32
fan-requested fair like hellboy 302
there are a ton of films that just can't
make it to our screens but for our money
these are the five movies that will
probably never see
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
five
I'll stay I suggest you hit sir I also
like to live dangerously back in the
late 90s and early 2000s your dad likely
had one really good impression sure he
had a backup Sean Connery but he'd save
his magnum opus for truly special
occasions your mum would egg him on and
then after a few session ales he'd stand
up and let rip do I make you horny baby
do I don't make you randy yeah after
three uber successful movies and
hundreds of thousands of embarrass
children the world over you'd think that
we would have seen more from the
international man of mystery but alas
since 2002's Goldmember the groovy penis
pump enthusiast has been
uncharacteristically quiet HBO purchased
the rights to make an Austin Powers
cartoon series back in nineteen ninety
nine but that never amounted to anything
I mean we did get Archer so I doubt
we'll ever see a powers cartoon come to
fruition just seriously Lana call Kenny
Loggins cuz you're in the danger zone
and since 2008 bombed the love guru oh
yes remember that one Mike Myers hasn't
really been starring in all that much
borrowing a cameo in inglorious basterds
and another shrek no yeah we're from it
of course although things look to all be
ogre for the Jolly Green Giant it seems
to be only living on in memes shrek is
love shrek is life back in 2007 Maya
said that he had an idea for the fourth
movie and that the story would be told
from dr. Evil's point of view in 2008 he
said that he was writing it and rumors
began to circulate that it will be
called for your thighs only nice when
pressed earlier this year my has
revealed that everything is being
negotiated and worked out and all that
stuff and here's a never-before-seen
photo of mike myers as he was answering
that question
[Music]
ever since we saw Master Chief saunter
off that Pelican and onto our screens we
knew he was destined for big things and
since the success of the first game
Microsoft had been pushing for a movie
but seeing as the film has languished
with in development hell for the best
part of a decade it's not looking likely
that we'll see our favorites button on
the big screen anytime soon alex garland
wrote the first draft of the movie way
back in two thousand six which was
pitched as studios by microsoft sending
couriers actually dressed as the chief
himself to the movie offices microsoft's
take 10 million dollars and wanted sent
the profits as well as casting choices
and first class plane tickets the movie
premiere how about new your crazy dutch
bastard as you might be able to guess
many studios passed up on the offer due
to the daph demands and a lack of
creative control but 20th Century Fox
and Universal Studios eventually joined
forces to get the production started
names like Peter Jackson and guillermo
del toro were tossed around to start
working on the movie but to cut down and
cost the studio's went with a young but
talented neill blomkamp DB vice yes the
game of thrones DB vice even lent a hand
in rewriting the script in 2006
eventually Blomkamp declared the film
was dead in 2007 and dreams of a
big-screen chief went up in smoke as the
rights returned to microsoft but it's
not all bad news after Blomkamp was
freed from movie stasis he was able to
go and work on the fantastic district
nine and to be honest i'd rather see a
district 10 but a hailer movie at this
point just let the big green spot and
rest
[Music]
my mama
mr Sandman is one of the most revered
comic-book properties of all times so
it's no surprise that Hollywood has been
dreaming of adapting it for the small
and big screen but dreams are the realm
of Morpheus and he's having none of it
despite his best efforts attempts to
adapt Sandman have repeatedly failed
Warner Brothers initially put Sandman
into development in the 1990s with pulp
fiction co-writer Roger Avery attached
and apparently he absolutely [ __ ] the
bed Neil Gaiman later described it as
quite easily the worst script he'd ever
read that will strike one and with the
movie hitting a brick wall warner
brothers decided to take a second crack
at Sandman but this time as a TV show
for this Warner Brothers tapped Eric
Kripke the creator of supernatural which
I maintain had an excellent first few
seasons and is well worth watching if
you're into handsome fellows hunting
demons and occasionally doing some
stellar lip-syncing work
according to Kripke this was for a lot
of varying reasons that were nobody's
fault don't lie to me Kripke someone's
always at fault it's probably the most
recent attempt was probably the closest
I ever came thanks in part to the
high-profile names attached to the
project Joseph gordon-levitt a vocal fan
of the Sandman signed on to play
Morpheus as well as produced and
directed Neil Gaiman even joined the
project as executive producer but alas
it wasn't meant to be and Joseph Gordon
left the movie citing creative
differences with Warner Brothers who
shifted custody of all DC vertical
adaptations to new line the sama movie
has an outright being cancelled but it's
difficult to imagine a future where it
actually exists as anyone that's read
the comic can attest to it's a story
that's inextricably linked to the medium
it was originally told in perhaps the
Sandman was only ever meant to be a
comic and anything more is just a fail
dream
[Music]
there's certainly been no shortage of
Stephen King book to movie adaptations
[Music]
but there's still a few languishing
around in development hell the Dark
Tower recently escaped after almost 10
years with the help of the world's worst
aw front cover but the one I'm lamenting
the most is the stand back in the 80s
King wanted horror maestro George a
Romero to direct a movie working from
his screenplay but due to the novel's
immense length of a thousand plus pages
cutting it down to fit into a
two-and-a-half-hour flick proved
difficult TV networks thought that a
show based on a book where ninety nine
point four percent of the world's
population choke on their own phlegm and
die was a bit too dark but King worked
his magic and got a mini-series on ABC
in 1995 king who was presumably still
reeling from Kubrick's version of The
Shining which he famously hated decided
that he would write a screenplay himself
despite King helming the writing and
having a pretty stellar cast the result
was a rambling miniseries that glossed
over the harsher element of Kings magnum
opus murr then in 2011 Warner Brothers
decided that they were interested in
creating a full-length movie of the
stand which then turned into a trilogy
which then turned into a multi film
project which then turned into a TV
miniseries which then turned into a
single three hour-long movie and then
maybe would be four feature-length
movies various directors and
screenwriters were attached including
batfleck before he left to become
batfleck the one that stuck was josh
boone director of The Fault in Our Stars
who talked openly about the project p
for abandoning it to go work on another
Stephen King adaptation revival maybe we
just shouldn't get our hopes up for this
one okay
Hollywood has an absolutely atrocious
track record of handling anime and manga
so the idea of adapting katsuhiro otomo
is groundbreaking akira is frankly
worrying now I'm not saying that it
can't be done successfully but the
business of making movies successful
worldwide is a huge stumbling block for
Kira and indelibly Japanese sci-fi story
although nothing has been officially
revealed about the akira adaptation
rumors have been rattling around the
internet for a while now and they've
upset a whole bunch of people not the
least of which is Star Trek actor George
Takei who responded to reports that the
movie was being whitewashed by starting
a petition because that always works
rumours indicated that the list of
actors being considered for the roles of
satsang and konoha include sparkling
vampire Robert Pattinson mediocre
spider-man Andrew Garfield Charles
Xavier with hair James McAvoy Tron dude
Garrett Hedlund Michael facyson bender
crapton Kirk Chris Pine Justin trouser
snake and Joaquin Phoenix's whole face
as shown by the ghost in the shell
adaptation which stars Scarlett
Johansson as Japanese protagonist major
Makoto Kusanagi Hollywood believes it
needs a listers to give niche properties
of fighting chance at the box office and
the unfortunate reality is that is just
not in the habit of casting Asian actors
in leading roles or finding more
suitable unknowns if you need proof
let's look at Goku from the dragonball
movie
that's gotta hurt casting alone could be
enough of a barrier to getting a clear
off the ground but there's also the
matter of the source material being a
complex exploration of society affected
by a nuclear attack otomo drew from
japan's own history with Hiroshima and
Nagasaki to depict his post apocalyptic
world and the characters within it maybe
I'm just being cynical but I think
without a personal connection and
Hollywood's fat cats calling the shots
we're more likely to get something like
youtube user Harry partridges American
Akira no time to talk guys evil
scientist and wrinkly children in flying
chairs are holding her friend tetsuo
captive and performing experiments on
him and the Proms tomorrow nevertheless
the akira movie is reportedly in
production with a reworked script from
harry potter movie scribe steve kloves
and fast & furious 6 director Justin Lin
being courted to helmet the akira movie
adaptation has a lot of big hurdles to
clear before it can be made and you know
what i will be totally okay if it fell
flat on its face
so unfortunately those the five movies
that we'll probably never see if there
are any films that you've got a
hankering for let us know in the
comments section below and for more
videos like this make sure you subscribe
to gamespot
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]